[Music]
is the idea that we are living in a
computer simulation a real possibility
or is this a sign that we can all be
victims to a hollywood fantasy my boss
nick bostrom wrote the paper about the
simulation argument so just quickly
outline it he argues that if we survive
and get iraq together as a species we're
going to develop in an advanced
post-human civilization with enormous
computing power
and at least some of that is going to be
used to run simulations of our past
because of entertainment historical
dramas or figuring out what really
happened in those important years in the
early 21st century and of course that's
going to be a lot of simulations so
hence it seems like if you're a mind in
the early 21st century
you might actually more likely be one of
the simulated minds rather than one of
the few minds that exist in the real
world so his paper ends up with a
trilemma we have to believe in at least
one really annoying or crazy thing
either that we will never reach this
post-human state that we will go extinct
because of some global disaster
or that post humans never do these
simulations may either because it's
impossible to actually do
or because we're all deciding oh that
would be totally unethical subjecting
people to the world of 2021 no that's
not ethical not even to simulated people
or the third possibility we're actually
happily simulated
well i don't like the simulation
argument but that's not in itself a good
reason to dismiss it
although it's pretty good
the simulation argument that anders
beautifully summarized is really weak in
a couple of ways firstly it asks us to
assign
probabilities to things that we have
really no idea how to assign
probabilities to what would our far
distant ancestors feel like doing with
with some extrapolation of the kinds of
technology that we have today people
have an idea of what a computer
simulation tends to mean probably
motivated by a desire that we might if
this is true we could upload ourselves
into the cloud and live forever uh so
we're asked to assign probabilities or
we don't have a good idea what those
probabilities should be
more importantly it's not just a
trilemma it's a i think it's a
quadrilateral i'm not even sure if that
is a word
there is a another fundamental
assumption
in all these ideas that is glossed over
and this is the idea that consciousness
is substrate independent as as bostrom
himself puts it in his lovely paper that
it doesn't matter whether
brains are made of carbon or silicon
that conscious that if you run the right
program on a computer of some kind
consciousness will happen he says this
is widely accepted in philosophy of mind
and in neuroscience it is somewhat
accepted but that's also not by everyone
and it's not obvious at all that this is
the case there are some things which if
you simulate them you bring them about a
computer playing chess actually is
playing chess there are other things
that if you simulate them
you you just simulate them you don't
actually instantiate them if you have a
a simulation of a weather system it
doesn't actually get wet it's a
simulation of a weather system so where
does consciousness lie on the spectrum i
don't actually know but i'm very
suspicious of assuming that it is
something that we can stimulate
basically that trilemma or that
quadrilema shows that there is something
wrong here something in the reasoning
that led us up to this situation is
really wonky and that is useful to know
then we might say okay i totally believe
that that one is not plausible at all
or
this tension we can investigate that
we can get in front of a whiteboard and
try to see if we i can make a
model that shows the right kind of local
symmetries we can get over to the
questions about wait a minute
credibility and plausibility and
possibility here maybe that is actually
breaking the argument but it notice that
these things are internal in some sense
to the philosophical thing it doesn't
tell us that much about whether this
reality is actually simulated for that
we need to look for pop-up windows or
some weird vagina and physics
i mean that leads me into the burning
question that i have i don't know about
any of you right now but like what would
it take to prove that like how are we
going to prove if we are or aren't in a
simulation
suppose we go out into space and finally
meet the aliens and they turn out to be
a real advanced super civilization and
they they are running zillions and
zillions of ancestor simulations of
their own ancestors in order to find out
some weird alien questions about history
that seems to be the kind of evidence
that would change our plausibilities a
bit because we know at least that looks
like there for some reason are able to
do then maybe we are assimilated you
want to try getting a grant for that
yes so first we need a space especially
a five-year grant yeah
happy to do it
well i think i think it's i mean it's
it's i think it is a little
it's a little much to ask of it to come
up with proof or evidence it doesn't
seem the kind of thing that evidence can
bear on in a useful way at least in the
near-term horizon i do think the value
of it in as much as there is
is in just probing some of the natural
sort of rivers of thinking that we tend
to apply ultimately i i i still think
there's great reason to be skeptical of
both the argument so we should
distinguish as well the argument which
is this trilemma or quadrilemma from the
hypothesis that this is actually the
case right so you could actually turn it
the other way around this is probably
really bad philosophy but you could turn
the other way around and say okay
this is actually a very the simulation
argument is a very good argument against
functionalism because um
if functionalism is true then the
simulation argument might follow and
that seems bonkers so let's not do that
uh but that's when that's not good but i
do think it's useful how it changes the
way we think i like it i don't think
bonkers doesn't necessarily mean that
argument is wrong
[Music]
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas